[Musique]
ce rien gagné jean claude bernard b au
nom du ministre de l'intérieur vous
désirez d'argent pour acte de courage et
de dévouement
il y avait un message particulier cette
année nous avons obtenu à honorer un
héros de la pénitentiaire et la
pénitentiaire qui est la troisième force
de sécurité intérieure était représenté
son front des troupes
vous le savez monsieur barnabé a eu un
acte de courage il y a quelques semaines
et nous avions discuté de la possibilité
de faire cette cérémonie en présence de
représentants de la pénitentiaire
c'était important oui je crois que c'est
important parce qu'on véhicule un
message de souvenirs et de ceux de paix
envers ceux qui ont combattu pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale mais c'est aussi
un message cilic finalement à ce qu'un
message d'engagement et c'est très
exactement le geste qu'il a eu à cette
occasion
à
c'est par ce jeu